muy buenas noches desde París
efectivamente pues no pudo ser para
Beatriz Maya que hizo un muy buen
partido ante higas gigante pero lo
cierto Es que la polaca hoy salió por
ese partido salió por la victoria de
manera muy determinada sobre todo en el
primer set que se llevó seis dos
imponiendo su ritmo de juego llevándose
prácticamente casi todos los puntos
jugando un tenis muy impecable antes que
veía uno tras otro los puntos desfilar
pero el segundo set fue mucho más
difícil hemos visto como la brasileña
Pues a lo largo de todo este torneo ha
llevado al menos cuatro de sus partidos
al tercer set le gustan esas batallas a
largas Allí es donde tal vez es cuando
más logra las victorias pero de hecho
tuvo la posibilidad de quedarse tuvo
bola para para un punto para quedarse
con ese set llevar las cosas a la
tercero y finalmente lo desaprovechó y
gas biantec también tuvo punto para el
partido pero ya no desaprovechó la
segunda vez y se quedó finalmente con la
victoria y ahora pues y Gante que
clasifica por segundo año consecutivo
final de Roland garros algo que nadie
más había logrado desde simonale entre
2017 y 2018 se cita entonces en esta
final ante Carolina mojoa la jugadora
checa que dio hoy la gran sorpresa tras
eliminar a harina zavalenca que era la
gran favorita para llegar a este final
es la jugadora número dos del mundo y de
hecho pues con esta derrota de sabalenka
y gas villante que hoy pues también
logra esta Victoria digamos por partida
doble no solamente porque está en la
final sino porque también este resultado
le permite conservar su Plaza como la
número uno del mundo